okay stuart i want to come back to you
and ask you about um what you think is
going to happen today
what just a couple of minutes until we
see the prime minister um it can't
really have gone down very well that
tobias elwood a senior conservative
lawmaker has today in the last hour
until the last couple of hours excuse me
told us that he's sending a letter of no
confidence in it
yeah well tobias
is a very good friend of mine i sit on
the defense select committee we were
both in the same regiment for all green
jackets however he was an officer i was
a rifleman and we fell different sides
of this argument i still respect him i
don't believe he's taken the right
decision and i've taken a different
decision to support the prime minister
and and that's what i need to do and i
believe 100 that the prime minister is
the right person to deliver for the
british people i felt so strongly about
that that that's why i wanted to push to
ensure that he stays in power and i
fully support him
okay richard stuart and toby thank you
so much for talking to us um two minutes
until pmq's so we will let you go there
and i'll turn now to our deputy
political editor sam coats who's here in
the studio with me
this morning sam it's going to be an
interesting one isn't it what are we
expecting
well the biggest question in british
politics at the moment is whether or not
the conservative party tory mps the
people that you see on the left of your
screen
still have confidence in boris johnson
now
that question is in play because on
monday
uh boris johnson had to answer questions
about what went on at the heart of power
the heist the pandemic and whether or
not his operation
and possibly even he saw events go on
that involved rule breaking and law
breaking and what we've seen over the
last few days is a drip drip drip not a
flood which might have happened but a
drip drip drip of mps coming out and
saying that they have no confidence now
in the last few moments you you name
checked uh tobias elwood he mentioned to
k burley this morning he put in a letter
of no confidence to
um uh graham brady if you get to 54 then
there's a vote of no confidence but
um uh he was number ten the tenth person
to come out and say that he had no
confidence in that in the prime minister
the ninth person came out yesterday now
he's nowhere near as famous as tobias
outward he isn't popping up on the sky
the whole time you don't know his uh
name most people he's called peter aldus
the waving emp in suffolk now he isn't
one of those individuals that holds the
limelight or particularly grandstands uh
when they uh when they do something like
that yet he
just said he couldn't put up with it
anymore and the combination of what
happened in denny's street and the way
that downing street dealt with this
tipped him over the line and i suspect
it will be peter alders
that danny street are more worried about
because
is there our silent majority of peter
alders on those conservative back
benches
uh worried that the damage done to the
prime minister's reputation the
struggles that boris johnson is having
to reset his government is too much or
as stuart anderson was saying uh to you
a moment ago
actually this government with an 80
street majority with boris johnson being
pretty much the only uh tory politician
that most tory mps think can uh knit
that electoral coalition together can
survive that's why the leveling up stuff
that you're talking about is so
interesting and and i thought it was
quite noteworthy that stuart anderson
was sort of trying to
ride two horses on the one hand saying
he's really excited about the white
paper which we'll hear about in an hour
or two and also that it was all
happening already but if it's all
happening already why do you need the
white paper and i think that that's why
actually what's happening is we're gonna
have to wait and see for the detail of
this white paper which we've been
talking about in anticipation for weeks
and weeks and weeks is a bit odd to be
honest can believe that that the prime
minister isn't personally fronting what
should be quite a big moment
uh michael gove will give a statement in
the comments as i say in about 90
minutes or so
and that will be
this phase of work unveiled yet boris
johnson
uh not uh not not leading on that uh and
i think that uh
there are just so many questions at the
moment uh as soon as tomorrow we might
get a big announcement about energy
prices
there is suggestions in this morning's
papers
that the government could effectively
give
taxpayer-backed loans to energy
companies to try and spread the increase
of costs
over several years to take effectively a
couple hundred quid off uh what
otherwise would be a 700 pound increase
in energy bills taking them to somewhere
in the region of 2000 pounds a year
that's the biggest issue facing uh many
many voters today
the cost of living uh crisis is upon us
now the leveling up white paper has a
much longer time frame uh delivery only
promised after the next one maybe two
general elections the date in the white
paper we understand for delivering is
2030. so you've got a mixture of
short-term crises that clearly the prime
minister is urgently uh wrapped in
discussing with chancellor richie sunak
and then you've got these longer term
things that even though they've been
built up for months uh are um uh uh are
also coming out today so i'm just gonna
stop you there um we've just gone 1202
let's have a listening to the speaker
we're waiting for pmq's members may not
accuse him of lying or deliberately
misleading the house unless such a
substantive motion is under
consideration
asking me is clear that it is to
preserve the character of parliamentary
debate
which i take to mean to stop it
descending into fruitless titles of
accusation and counter accusation
may i also say that expressions when
used in respect of the members which are
regarded with particular seriousness
generally leading to prompt intervention
from the chair and often requirement on
a member to withdraw the words include
charges uttering deliberate falsehoods
it is important
to stress context
similar words said in different
proceedings might attract a different
response from the church depending on
the subject being debated
tone and other considerations but in
general the chur will not tolerate
accusations of lying or deliberately
misleading the house
that
is the long-standing practice of the
house
as set out in this in may and followed
by successive speakers and deputy
speakers of course long-standing
practices may change for example if the
house decided it wanted a different
approach perhaps informed by the
procedure committee inquiry but it's not
for me to change the practice
unilaterally
therefore
i ask members to respect this repro
approach i know feelings run high on
important issues we discuss but there
are plenty of ways of making strong
feelings felt within the rules and
without placing the chair in the
invidious position of having to order
members to withdraw on seeking their
suspension
before we come to premises questions i'd
like to point out the british sign
language interpretation of proceedings
is available to watch on poland live tv
i now call esther mike bay
question number one mr speaker
prime minister mr speaker
this
this sunday
her majesty the queen will become the
first british monarch to celebrate a
platinum jubilee
while it is a moment for national
celebration it will be a day of mixed
emotions for her majesty as of course
the day also marks 70 years since the
death of her beloved father george vi
i know that the whole house will want to
join me in thanking her majesty for her
tireless service we look forward to
celebrating her historic reign with a
series of national events in june
mr speaker
this morning i had meetings
i had meetings with ministerial
colleagues and others
in addition to my duties in this house i
shall have further such meetings later
today
on monday the secretary of state for
health said mandatory vaccinations would
be subject to a consultation so can the
prime minister make it clear
unequivocally no ifs no buts no
qualifications that mandatory
vaccinations for nha staff will be
abandoned
will you also make it clear that is true
for care workers as well many of whom
have already lost their jobs so what
support will the government be giving to
get those care workers back into the
care sector and will those who've lost
their jobs get compensation
uh i i thank my right honourable friend
very much for her thoughtful uh work on
this i want to stress
that uh vaccines remain our best line of
defense and i do think that nhs staff
and all those who work in uh in in the
care sector have a professional
responsibility to get vaccinated mr
speaker but as my right home professor
health secretary told the house on
monday uh given the difference between
omicron and delta it is right and she is
right that we revisit the balance of
risks and opportunities mr speaker the
health secretary has said we'll launch a
consultation and subject to the
responses and the will of this house mr
speaker the government will revoke the
regulations
we now come to the leader of the
opposition the writer will kierstama
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker i'm following your
opening remarks i just want to say to
the members opposite
theirs is the party of winston churchill
our parties stood together as we
defeated fascism in europe
now their leader stands in the house of
commons parroting the conspiracy
theories of violent fascist to try and
score cheap political points
he knows
he knows exactly what he is doing it's
time to restore some
dignity mr speaker
one of the most absurd claims made on
behalf of operation save big dog
is the prime minister the chancellor
writing in the sunday times that they
are the tax-cutting conservatives
why do these alleged tax cuts keep
raising taxes on working people
prime minister mr speak on his first
point i don't want to make heavy weather
of this but i am informed that in 2013
uh the right honourable gentleman
apologized and took full responsibility
for what had happened on on his watch
and i think mr speaker that was the
right thing to do
and mr speaker on
on on
on what we're doing to tackle uh cost of
living and taxation mr speaker our kovid
recovery plan our coverage plan is
absolutely vital in helping people with
the cost of living lifting up universal
credit payments mr speaker by cutting
the tax that people uh the cutting the
tax that people effectively pay lifting
the living wage mr speaker uh helping
councils with another half a billion
pounds uh for those who are facing
particular hardship mr speaker but what
we're what we're also doing and this is
absolutely vital is increasing the
number of high-wage high-skill jobs in
this country 420 000 more on the payroll
than there were before the pandemic
began because we've had the fast exact
exit from covid of any european economy
mr speaker because we have the fastest
backed vaccine and booster rollout
[Applause]
[Music]
mr speaker it's not just the national
insurance rise thresholds for income tax
frozen a stealth tax on working people
the threshold for tuition fees frozen a
stealth tax on working people
local authorities forced to increase
council tax a stealth tax on working
people
you can be as stealthy as you like but
you can't hide reality we have the
highest tax burden for 70 years
during the middle of an inflation crisis
so i asked the prime minister again why
did he and the chancellor keep raising
taxes on working people
[Music]
by melissa mr speaker what we are doing
is helping people with that with the
cost of living cutting taxes for those
on universal credit mr speaker as i have
said uh helping people with the cost of
their fuel mr speaker with the cold
weather payments uh the warm homes
payments mr speaker doing all the things
that this country would expect lifting
the living wage which this party mr
speaker introduced this party this
government has increased by the record
amount uh mr speaker and what we and
above all and one above all the most
important thing that we are doing is
helping people into work 500 000 people
off welfare into worse under our way to
work scheme more people more people in
work now than before the pandemic began
and that is the record is coming
labour never forget mr speaker there's
never been a labor government that left
office with unemployment lower than when
they are
check that out
[Music]
lots of words lots of bluster no answers
word of warning
word of warning prime minister that's
not going to work with the police
[Music]
i'll tell him i'll tell him why they're
putting taxes up low growth in the
decade of tory government before the
pandemic growth slumped it was much much
weaker than under the last labor
government
if the tories matched our record on
growth
we would have 30 billion pounds more to
spend on public services without having
to raise a single tax
mr speaker surely even this prime
minister doesn't need someone else to
tell him that he and the chancellor are
having to raise taxes because the tories
failed to grow the economy over a decade
no mr speaker i think everybody in this
country uh can see that we've been
through the biggest pandemic uh since uh
for a hundred years that we've looked
after the people of this country to the
tune of 400 billion pounds that we've
put into furlough and all the other
schemes 11.7 million people protected
everybody knows everything everybody
knows the cost of that mr speaker and at
the same time in spite of all the
difficulties that we have faced uh we
have now got the fastest growth in the
g7 absolutely true
we've got youth unemployment we've got
youth unemployment at a record low mr
speaker we've got three times as much
tech investment investment coming into
this country as there is in france twice
as much twice as much as there is in
germany yes that's absolutely true mr
speaker and never forget if you want to
know about labour economics never forget
the last time they were in office mr
speaker when they were finally booted
out they left a note saying there's no
money left that's the way that's the way
they run the country mr speaker
mr speaker
the uk
some people won't be getting more
because they won't be here to hear it so
yes
mr speaker the uk has suffered the worst
economic crisis in the g7 the prime
minister's more chance of persuading the
public that he didn't hold any parties
than he has of persuading them that the
economy is booming
high taxes are not just the result of
low growth under this government we've
seen a pandemic of waste and fraud
from the prime minister's yacht to
government contracts for mates of
ministers they've treated taxpayers as
an atm machine for their mates and their
lifestyles
now we find now we find mr speaker
they've written off 8.7 billion pounds
on ppa
and the chancellor's writing of 4.3
billion in fraud
that's enough to cover the tax hike he's
inflicting on working people
so why did this government block the
national prime agency from investigating
all the billions they lost to fraud
mr speaker of course we despise fraud
and those who steal from the taxpayer
and that's why we've already recovered
743 million pounds in lost furlough
money mr speaker 2.2 billion pounds that
was stolen in bounce back loans and we
will go on but i have to tell you mr
speaker that i am proud of what this
government in this country did in
securing record quantities of ppe and
record time uh mr speaker in furloughing
and looking after the entirety of
british business and society in the way
that we did mr speaker and once again
captain hindsight comes to this house
and attacks the government for doing
exactly what he urged us to do 18 months
ago mr speaker it so happens that i have
a i've found a letter i've been
wrestling in my notes mr speaker
and i found a letter which i will place
for your convenience in the house in the
library of the house mr speaker from the
from the shadow chancellor uh to my
rival the secretary of state for deluxe
suggesting uh that we could secure ppe
supplies on april the 22nd uh 2020
secure ppe supplies uh from a a football
sorry from a theatrical customer and
that we could get ventilators from a
professional football agent uh mr
speaker no wonder no wonder
no wonder under labour no wonder under
labour fraud was running at 21 billion
pounds per year mr speaker i'm proud of
what this government did to secure
this
people
here's tom
who wants some of the fish to leave
please put your hand up because i'm
going to pick one of you kirsten
mr speaker the primus might want to
sharpen how he answers questions under
interview
he's going to need it in the next few
weeks
waste and low growth explain why we have
high taxes but they don't explain why
it's always working people that are
asked to pay more
yesterday he ordered his troops not to
support a windfall tax on oil and gas
companies
as a result the country is missing out
on over a billion pounds we could have
used to cut taxes on energy bills for
working people today he's ordering his
troops to vote for tax cuts for banks
as a result the country is missing out
on another billion pounds we could have
spent cutting taxes for working people
why are the chance from the prime
minister protecting oil companies and
bank profits while putting taxes up on
working people
mr speaker let's let's just get to the
heart of what this is all about this is
all about this is all about dealing
dealing with the consequences of the
biggest pandemic this country has seen
with an unprecedented economic crisis in
which the state had to come forward and
look after the people of this country to
the tune of 408 billion pounds that
everybody can see the fiscal impacts of
that shall i tell you uh what this
government and this country is voting
for and what we're doing
we're investing now in 45 000 more nhs
workers more people in our nhs this year
than there were last year 10 000 more
nurses 10 900 more nurses about 5 000
more doctors
9 million more scams 100 community
diagnostics hubs to help people to get
the scans and treatment they need and
the incredible thing the incredible the
lamentable thing is that the party
opposite the party of naiban mr speaker
voted against those funds voted against
that investment and they would have made
our code recovery impossible
[Applause]
mr speaker for all the bluster the truth
is
the conservative party or the party of
high taxes because they're the party of
low growth
they are the party of high taxes because
they're the party of eye-watering waste
mr speaker we know this prime minister
has no respect for decency or honesty
i can take it
i can take it when it's aimed at me
but i won't accept it when he gaslights
the british public writing
absurd articles about cutting taxes at a
time when he's squeezing working people
to the pips
isn't it the case mr speaker that he and
his chancellor are the tory thelma and
louise hand in hand as they drive the
country off the cliff and into the abyss
of low growth and attacks
mr gullis i think you've been trailed
for long enough and you don't want to be
thrilled anymore and that is the last
comment to have her otherwise i will
ring your mother kierster
isn't it true mr speaker
that he and the chancellor are the tory
felmer and louise hand in hand as they
drive the country off the cliff and into
the abyss of low growth and high taxes
[Applause]
well mr speaker i think i think the
right honourable gentleman is dick
dastardly and and mutley
[Applause]
both of them pulling in different
directions uh we know and we know they
have different views uh mr speaker we
we are getting on we are getting on with
the job uh mr speaker and justin just in
the last few days and of course i i
think it's absolutely extraordinary that
they've done nothing to support our
kobed recovery plan they voted against
our plans to support the nhs but what
we're doing just in the last in the last
few days while he's been fixated on
on the issues that he's absolutely
determined to uh to escalate what we've
done uh we've opened free ports across
the country just in the last in the last
few days we're getting 500 000 people
off welfare into work with our way to
work plan
in just a few short minutes mr speaker
if i hope you will hang around because
you will hear my right honourable friend
the secretary of state for leveling up
deliver the long-awaited leveling up
white paper
full
full of full of good stuff um including
55 education investment areas 55
education investment areas across our
country a wonderful moral and economic
mission to level up and give opportunity
across the whole country a fantastic
vision for this country mr speaker they
have nothing of the kind to offer the
people of this country mr speaker while
we are getting on with coming out of
covid with the second fastest uh with
the fastest economic recovery in the g7
the fastest the fastest he would have
kept us he would have kept us in
lockdown mr speaker we're fixing the nhs
we're fixing the nhs and social care
when they voted against it and they have
no plan and we are well mr speaker we
are building a coalition
we are building a coalition
prime minister i'm this way not that way
maybe spec savers might be the answer to
where i am and i can i just say
dame caroline downage is desperate to
get the next question to you
dame diana carolina
thank you very much mr speaker i'd like
to first of all give my condolences to
the right normal member for camberwell
and peckham
how good it is to see her back in her
place
mr speaker sophie farrell was just 10
years old when she died in september
childhood cancer
is often described as rare
yet cancer is the biggest killer of
children under 4 under 14. sophie's gp
failed to diagnose her cancer and it was
only when she went to a e that they
discovered the tumor in her little body
that was 12 centimeters long so
mr speaker on world cancer day on friday
i would like to ask the prime minister
to please advocate for more and better
training for general practice to
identify cancer in children
prime minister i thank my honorable i'm
very sorry to hear of uh sophie's case
and my thoughts are with her her family
and her and her friends and she's right
that research is uh crucial in uh in
tackling childhood cancers uh that's why
we're we're investing in uh more
research but it's also vital uh that we
do tests and uh and diagnostic scans and
screens uh early enough and that's why
it's also important uh that
nice has not only updated its guidance
on referring childhood cancers in
february uh 20 uh february last year but
we're investing in 100 new diagnostic
centers in community hubs i now come to
the leader of the snp
thank you mr speaker and i'm sure that
you and the rest of the house will want
to join me in celebrating and supporting
world cancer day
mr speaker just in relation to your
earlier statement
i have a difficulty reconciling the
prime minister's version of events with
other evidence and as you know
i have a duty to reflect
and represent the deep deep public anger
with the prime minister that said mr
speaker
i respect the absolute impartiality that
you take in your role and i want to set
on the record that i respect both you
and the authority of the chair
mr speaker
this morning the telegraph newspaper
revealed that the prime minister
attended a party
in his flat
on the 13th of november 2020.
the prime minister
previously told the house
that no party took place
the police are now investigating this
party
and we face a very real prospect of a
sitting prime minister
being questioned under caution
and being fined in office
and if he is questioned mr speaker he
must go
if he's fined
he must resign
mr speaker
you'll agree
that the house should not be treated
with contempt
so can the prime minister
here we go here we go again
so can the prime minister update the
house
on his whereabouts
on the evening of the 13th of november
surely surely mr speaker he doesn't need
to wait for an investigation to tell us
exactly where he was
prime minister uh well mr speaker here
we go again says the uh the right
honourable gentleman opposite and i must
say uh that those are entirely my
feelings he asked exactly the same
questions as i recall in the of the in
the chamber a few days ago he knows mr
speaker that the process must go on but
i can tell him what's been going on in
downing street uh mr speaker
in november and throughout we've been
delivering the fastest vaccine and
booster rollout anywhere in europe uh
we've been getting people back into work
mr speaker we've been getting people
back back into work mr speaker and uh
we've been helping to bring the west
together
to defy what i think is completely
unacceptable threats and intimidation
from the putin regime against ukraine
and that's what we've been doing
in blackfoot
thank you mr speaker i mean that was a
disgraceful response and i have to say
to the prime minister he should read the
room and it should see some of the faces
on his colleagues faces he has lost it
mr speaker
we've now reached
the ridiculous scenario
of a prime minister
who can't even tell us where he was
exactly he lives in a world
where he thinks everything is odd to him
and he never pauses to think
what he owes to the public
the prime minister is now a dangerous
distraction at home
and a running joke on the international
stage
what does it tell the prime minister and
the public that in the morning that he
has returned from ukraine the chair of
the defense select committee has
submitted a letter of no confidence in
him
prime minister
mr speaker what uh it tells me that is
more vital than ever uh for the
government of this country to get on
with the job deliver our co-bid recovery
plan and that is what we are doing
virginia
mr mr speaker i would like to say dioc
thank you to the prime minister for
visiting my honor small constituency
when he saw firsthand the enormous
beneficial impact a new nuclear plant
will know it could have it built on
anglesey nuclear power must play a role
if we are to meet our carbon and net
zero commitments level up and combat
rising energy prices does my right
honourable friend agree that the rapid
deployment of nuclear technology must be
a priority for this government and if so
will my right on raw friend commit to
financing a nuclear plant at the wilbur
site this parliament
[Applause]
well it was a great joy to visit uh my
honourable friend's constituency where i
believe she is known as atomic kitten or
so she also she so she informed me mr
speaker uh and uh she outlined in great
detail her uh her plans for uh for
welfare
it's a it's a it's a fantastic vision a
fantastic site and uh it remains a very
interesting and attractive prospect for
new nuclear power
color meshwork thank you mr speaker i'm
not sure if the prime minister has
noticed but while he's been partying
working families in northern ireland
have lost a thousand pounds from their
universal credit their national
insurance has been put up by this
government and their energy bills are
going through the ruth he's very fond of
telling us that we're all in this
together isn't it the truth mr speaker
that this prime minister has only ever
been in it for himself and his rich
mates
[Music]
no mr speaker i'm in it to serve my
country and the entire united kingdom
and i'm also proud that we've had the
biggest we've had the biggest investment
in northern ireland uh since devolution
began and uh we've cut taxation on
universal credit
uh
thank you mr speaker
southwestern railway has totally cut off
dorset
somerset most of wiltshire and devon
from its direct rail services to london
as well as slashing our service in half
most of which is totally unnecessary
well my right honourable friend support
me and my neighbouring colleagues in
getting direct services back to west
dorset and having a timetable that's fit
for our region
i want to thank my honorable friend very
much for his question and he knows where
of he speaks he's an expert in this
subject mrs mr speaker and he's lobbied
uh very effectively for his constituents
and reflected their frustrations and i'm
told that the timetable is expected to
return to december 22 21 levels from
saturday the 19th of february
alexis thank you mr speaker i was out
this weekend speaking to a constituent
who has a cold and leaky house she has
seen her bills already got from 100 to
170 pounds a month the government have
failed to insulate her house and fail to
control her fuel bills bribing people
with their own money is no plan the
prime minister has no plan to cut vat no
plan to get the oil and gas industry to
contribute another constituent who voted
for the prime minister went further and
called him despicable what use is a
prime minister who has no plan for
families struggling with the cost living
and has lost the trust of the people of
this country
well mr speaker he talks about cutting
vat i wonder whether he voted uh for
brexit and our ability to cut uh vat
that's it
that's even indicative perhaps
[Applause]
which we delivered mr speaker and his
anniversary we celebrated uh on monday
and what we're doing mr speaker is and i
sympathize i sympathize very much uh
with his constituent and i understand
the pressures that people are facing on
the cost of living but what we've got to
do what we've got to do is invest in uh
and then protect them we're putting 12
billion pounds worth of support and
financial help uh for families in
hardship this year and it's absolutely
vital after the pandemic but the most
important thing is to have a jobs-led
economic recovery in case i fail to make
myself clear before you wow me up mr
speaker that's why we have the fastest
economic growth in the g7
[Music]
thank you mr speaker
the greater manchester mayoral
clean air zone scheme effectively a
congestion charge affecting all 500
square miles of greater manchester
including my constituents in lee is a
job destroying tax
fault
we all want clean air but the model
proposed by mayor burnham is unworkable
and economically devastating
with charges of 60 pounds per day
per lorry driver
taxis white van men
even buses will be caught by it
will the pm intervene to prevent mayor
burnham from inflicting this disastrous
labour scheme on greater manchester
united
i know from my own experience how vital
it is when you're trying to clean up air
in a great city that you do not unjustly
penalize business in particularly uh
small businesses and it's become clear
that the scheme proposed by the labour
mayor in manchester is completely
unworkable will do more damage to
businesses and residents in manchester
so we must find
an alternative mr speaker that doesn't
punish local residents and my right
honourable friend the secretary of state
uh for the environment will be saying
more about this in the coming days
thank you mr speaker if the prime
minister receives a penalty fixed notice
for attending a party or hosting the
party during lockdown will he inform the
house and will he resign
yes or no prime minister mr speaker of
course i will comply with the law but
i've got to wait for the i've got to
wait for the process to be concluded
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker
since being elected my fabulous
constituency of blythe valley is really
seeing the green shoots of prosperity
government support is a green revolution
in blyth valley however with such growth
the increased congestion on our roads we
are in desperate need of upgrades to the
road infrastructure would my right
honourable friend please meet with me to
discuss the urgent problem and help
blind valley out of the ever increasing
traffic jam thank you
prime minister
my my honorable friend is the best
champion that blithe could possibly have
you guys he does a quite amazing job and
i want to thank him in particular mr
speaker for helping to secure the the
british vote gigafactory uh involved
absolutely amazing uh investment and uh
we i i understand that of course growth
and prosperity bring its uh uh bringing
their challenges when it comes to
congestion on our roads we have to
tackle that we're working with the
council on a uh on a bid for the bright
the blythe uh relief road and i'll make
sure that my honourable friend gets a
meeting with the transport secretary to
discuss it further rachel
thank you mr speaker the problem with a
distracted prime minister is that he
makes the wrong choices while he's been
living it up
many of my constituents are living on
the red line as food energy and taxes
shoot up
in york the rent prices are the highest
now in the north and some of the highest
in the country and york is now in the
top 10 places in the country where there
is a cost of living crisis pushing my
constituents further into poverty and
debt
so when is he going to stop protecting
himself
and start protecting my constituents
so so
mr speaker one of the first things i did
uh when i became prime minister was to
ensure was to ensure that we looked
after people on low incomes by
increasing local housing allowance mr
speaker
by increasing the living wage uh not
once but twice and by record amounts mr
speaker and of course uh by doing what
we've now done with universal credit but
the most important i really think the
house needs to to get this but the most
important thing about the uk economy
right now is that we have a strong
jobs-led recovery and that is what is
going to drive up wages and drive up
productivity and drive up growth and
that is what this government is
delivering
so desmond swain
will he will he brief us on his visit to
uh ukraine
uh
mr speaker i thank my my honourable
friend very much and in in in in very
briefly uh mr speaker i can tell the
house that uh the mission was to as i
hope everybody will support was to stand
shoulder to shoulder with uh with
ukraine uh for the house of our country
to show that we stand uh with the people
of ukraine and we stand for the
sovereign and territorial integrity of
ukraine at a very difficult time because
there are on the borders of ukraine as
everybody knows about 125 000 uh russian
troops massing uh the situation is is
very perilous and the job of the uk is
to lead the west in bringing together uh
the most important countries in uh
creating a package of economic sanctions
that will deter president putin from
what i believe would be a disastrous
miscalculation and also to strengthen
our support uh for the ukraine and for
the ukrainian people and indeed the
ukrainian army and uh we're doing that
we're supplying lethal but defensive
weaponry as well as training to the
ukraine so that is that is greatly
appreciated but i must say that the
situation remains a risky mr speaker and
it is vital that diplomacy finds a way
forward thomas mr speaker on a related
issue after the publication of the
russia report the prime minister claimed
tackling illicit finance and driving
dirty money and money launders out of
the uk is a priority
his warnings to mr putin of late would
surely have carried more bite if he'd
actually used the 18 months since
publication of the russia report to
legislate for an economic crime act to
stop the flow of dirty money for russia
why hasn't he prioritized this issue of
national security
[Music]
[Applause]
mr speaker contrary to contrary to the
uh some of the myths that are peddled
this government has come down very hard
on dirty money from russia and
everywhere else that's why we brought in
the unexplained wealth orders uh and
indeed china mr speaker
which they might like to they might like
to to consider that we have that's why
we have sanctions on russia following
what they did in crimea in in 2014 we
have magnitsky sanctions on everybody
involved in the poisoning of alexi
navalny and to his point this is because
we are bringing forward the economic uh
crime bill so that it will take place it
will be voted on in the third session of
this parliament
thank you mr speaker despite the best
efforts of the opposition
two years ago this week this government
delivered the democratic decision to
leave
and despite there being a global
pandemic in the two years since over 70
free trade agreements have been signed
however as we recover there are many
more opportunities that can be realized
so will the prime minister commit to
appointing a minister responsible for
realizing those brexit freedoms and
benefits that will boost all of our
constituencies
mr speaker you can hear from the the
chantering opposite that they still want
to take this thing back they still they
still want to cancel uh brexit mr
speaker but it was thanks to brexit very
largely that we actually we had the
fastest vaccine rollout in europe mr
speaker and we've been able to deliver
our free ports uh mr speaker uh and uh
we've been able to do 60 or 70 free
trade deals around the world and yes mr
speaker i'm not going to anticipate any
decisions i may make about the
government but i certainly think it
would be a good idea uh to have a
minister driving uh that post-brexit
agenda
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah thank you let's just
recap mr speaker before we're told we
must wait for the sugray report
then we're told we must wait for the
police investigation to conclude we had
there was no party
and then if there was a party i wasn't
there then well if
there was a party then all rules were
forward
but no one no one prime minister
believes you
and if any of the above any of the above
were true why did alexis stratton have
to resign
yeah prime minister mr speaker i
explained that's uh that sad matter uh
on the floor of the house uh and and no
no nobody no but nobody wanted allegra
uh to resign and i was i was very sad uh
that she did
seven job
thank
[Applause]
my constituent gt
sharon from exmouth has launched a
campaign to get a dedicated metaphors
clinic in devon
women in east devon currently face a 120
mile round trip to get the nearest
specialist menopause clinic it's not
good enough is it no will my right
honourable friend outline what steps the
government is taking to improve access
to menopause services in devon and the
south west
prime minister well i thank my
honourable friend for raising this very
important campaign and we are committed
to improving menopause care so that all
women can have access to uh to the
support they need and and to manage uh
the symptoms menopause will be a
priority within our women's health
strategy and uh we're committed to
establishing a uk-wide menopause task
force mr speaker dave angela reedle
thank you uh mr speaker
if the prime minister needs a
metropolitan police inquiry to tell him
whether he attended a party on the 13th
of november in his own downing street
flat
why should we believe that he's a fit
and proper person to have his hand on
the button of our independent nuclear
deterrent
[Applause]
well mr speaker i i hesitate to i
hesitate to remind the right honorable
lady but she campaigned actively to
install a prime minister who wanted to
get with
everybody to get rid of our nuclear
terror together
[Applause]
marcus
thank you mr
[Music]
the speaker minister the government and
our nhs have done an amazing job with
the vaccine rollout making it a
resounding success
would my right honourable friend join me
in thanking the wonderful nhs workers
volunteers and pharmacies who have
worked so hard to help make these
possible in jews murfield kirkburn and
denmary dale
minister
i thank my honorable friend who does a
fantastic job of representing his
communities and i want to thank all of
them mr speaker everybody involved in
the roller in jews brian murfield in
kirk burton and in denbigh dale uh mr
speaker because it was an extraordinary
national effort and anybody who visited
a vaccine center will know that feeling
of pride in what was happening that
feeling of energy in a collective effort
to make our society and our country
literally healthier day by day and i i
thank all of them mr speaker from the
bottom of my heart
that's the end of pmq so those who wish
to leave please do so quietly and
quickly
so there you go boris johnson facing 30
minutes of questions from the house the
first pmq's since the publication of
that su great update as it was called on
the downing street lockdown parties our
deputy political editor sam coats is in
central lobby let's go straight to sam
and speak to him so sam where did that
pmq's leave us
well the question that we asked before
prime minister's questions was
would what we saw over the last 35
minutes really changed the market when
it came to tory mps and their confidence
in boris johnson for after all this
prime minister remains in office only if
those people sitting behind him choose
to allow him to do so and although it
was a rambunctious 35 minutes or so i'm
not sure that anything that we heard
markedly change uh that calculation what
we didn't get
was what we've had at some of the other
recent parliamentary
moments which is figures like andrew
mitchell on monday or david davis a
couple of weeks ago
saying outright that boris johnson
should go there wasn't a moment like
theresa may on monday
questioning the integrity of the prime
minister so from that point of view
there were no uh big changes instead you
saw at times a really quite um tetchy at
point uh quite unpleasant exchange
particularly between the two party
leaders
kirstama seeking to get off on the front
foot attacking boris johnson for the
comments he made yesterday uh or on
monday about uh kierstama's role as head
of the uh director as director of public
prosecutions uh at a time where jimmy
sapple wasn't prosecuted kierstarma got
off on the front foot on that subject
accusing the prime minister of
essentially echoing far-right conspiracy
theories boris johnson replied by
pointing out that uh kirsten had been in
charge to provide to that period had
apologized for some of the failings of
the wider
department for public prosecutions so
that one of the nastier debates in
politics at the moment one of those
things that does appear to be motivating
the way that mps are behaving to buy us
elwood of course this morning saying
that he put in a letter of no confidence
in part because he disliked what the
prime minister said on monday appearing
uh to uh link uh kyocerma with the
decision over jimmy savile the failure
to prosecute even though uh kierstarma
didn't have a direct role uh in that
decision moreover kirstama's job today
was to try and make the tory
backbenchers feel uncomfortable he did
that by concentrating on the fact that
boris johnson says in that article in
the sunday times at the weekend that he
is a tax cutter yet you do have that
long list of tax rises uh on the horizon
they include the national insurance rise
1.25 percent on employers and employees
and you've got council tax going up and
you've got some freezes on thresholds
most recently to student tuition fees
which effectively uh mean that students
uh having to repay pay back loans will
have to pay back uh more for his part
boris johnson was pointing out that he'd
had to spend 400 billion pounds fighting
and supporting the economy during the
pandemic and that's the reason why there
are some pressures kierstarma tried to
point out that uh there are still tax
cuts on things like banking uh boris
johnson insisting that there are areas
in which the government uh is helping uh
so no bombshells in today's prime
minister's questions but kirstama quite
laser-like trying to focus on making
tories who dislike the prime minister's
language and dislike the prime
minister's wider policy platform feel
uncomfortable boris johnson uh trying to
show he still got lead in the pencil
willing to fight
and hitting back at the criticism
sam thank you
we have some breaking news this
afternoon and that is that the royal air
force have confirmed that typhoon jets
have been scrambled to respond to what
they're calling an unidentified aircraft
approaching the united kingdom the jets
took off from raf lossy mouth in murray
in scotland and they were joined by a
voyager air-to-air refuelling tanker and
that aircraft went from raf bryson
norton in oxfordshire
an raf spokesman has declined to prefer
to provide any further detail on the
operation until it is over so as soon as
we have any more information from the
raf we'll bring that to you so just to
update you the raf says typhoon jets
have been scrambled to respond to an
unidentified aircraft approaching the uk
more on that as soon as we get it to
other news now the kremlin has accused
the white house of
whipping up tensions over ukraine in
order to start a war those comments came
ahead of prime minister boris johnson's
delayed call with the russian president
vladimir putin this afternoon any
british intervention is unlikely to
produce the hopeful progress though
after one of moscow's top diplomats told
sky news that british diplomacy is
making the situation worse our u.s
correspondent martha counter reports
after a flying visit to ukraine the
standoff continues the prime minister
and russian president putin due to speak
on the phone today as the threat of war
looms large it goes without saying that
a further
russian
invasion
of ukraine
would be a political disaster a
humanitarian disaster
in my view would also be
for russia
for the world a military disaster as
well
today's call is the latest attempt to
call an escalating crisis speaking for
the first time since december president
putin accused the west of goading russia
into war and now one of his top
diplomats telling sky news